should you mix business with pleasure a
lot of entrepreneurs have a limiting
belief that you go to your business just
for business and then you have your life
just your life and I'm of the opinion I
believe that everything gets stronger
when you can mix those things together
if you can bring more of your personal
life and your personal beliefs into your
business you'll have a lot more fun
you'll be more fulfilled from it people
will connect you better because it's not
just a company now it's a it's a person
and if you can bring more of your
business to your personal life you'll
find that people can relate to you
better can understand what you go
through can maybe give you some
connections it's not like you're you're
forcing yourself on people I'm not
saying you should be out you know and
every personal dinner you're having with
friends hard selling them on what you're
selling you know and I don't believe
that you need to be in your in your own
business always just talking about your
personal life but there's a mix you
don't have to keep them separated and I
think as entrepreneurs our business
lives and our personal lives are so
intertwined and that's a special
relationship that if you take them apart
I think will hurt you because what
you're doing your business around is
hopefully an extension of who you are
and you're doing your business because
you're passionate about something you
really believe in something so that's
that's a part of you that's like your
second leg that that's a part of what
you're all about so why would you want
to hide that why would you feel ashamed
of of telling people about that and your
personal life if you can bring that
element to your business people will
connect with you better and will be more
likely to bar for you because people
like buying from people and not from
companies just an example of how these
things are so mixed together I run these
mastermind groups here in Toronto and
every month a group of entrepreneurs we
get together we talk about our
businesses we try to help each other out
at the end of the meeting we'll go to
the computer and enter in our goals of
what we want to have happen for the next
month and there's always two business
goals and one personal goal
because our lives are so intertwined
then they started off as three business
goals and the member said hey what about
adding some personal goals in on here
too and it could be something as simple
as you know show my wife how much I love
her or you know run three times a week
or you know go learn salsa dancing
something like that but but it's so
mixed up into what makes us happy right
if you want to be happy as an
entrepreneur you need to have your
personal life happy and you need to have
your business life happy if your
business is suffering you're not gonna
be happy as an entrepreneur if you're if
your home life sucks
you're not gonna be happy either and so
part of being a happy entrepreneur is
getting everything working together and
sharing that with people with the people
in your life makes them understand you
better and connect you better so all
this is as a result of a question a
really long question that came in from
one of my newsletter readers Andrea and
Andrea basically has a whole bunch of
businesses she has a new book she's got
all these things going on and she wants
to launch her own personal website and
his wondering can she share her business
stuff on her personal website or should
she just keep it separate and in my mind
I don't know how you keep it separate I
mean you so you want to make it tasteful
not just say hey go buy my book it's the
greatest thing ever
but the book is part of you right like
your experiences in your personal life
to led to creating this book so why
wouldn't you want to share it right
bring yourself into your business and
your business into your person like you
mix them up you'll feel better people
will understand you more you'll be
happier and you'll make more money
believe for those of you watching like
the video give it a thumbs up below let
me know what you think do you agree
disagree leave a comment below have a
question leave it in the comment section
I'll give you a reply thank you guys so
much if you want to see more videos like
this please subscribe below and I'll see
you soon
you